first professor stephen cohen is one of
the famous russia experts the eminent
russia experts in america he's professor
emeritus at nyu was at princeton for
many years now a contributing editor at
the nation magazine and he joins us
tonight for some perspective on this
conversation about russia professor you
have followed this country for fifty
years and know many of its leaders
personally give us a sense of what's at
stake in this conversation about russia
for the united states for 75 years the
President of the United States beginning
with Roosevelt has met the leader of the
Kremlin beginning with Eisenhower in the
Atomic Age the main purpose was to avoid
war with Russia right now we are in a
new Cold War fraught with hot war from
Ukraine to the Baltic region to Syria
President Trump did not have a choice he
had to go as his predecessors did to
meet with the leader of the Kremp Outen
and he did we don't know exactly what
they decided we will learn but never
never not only in my lifetime or history
as a president coming back from doing
his duty to avoid war with Russia been
greeted with this pornography passing as
news analysis in commentary he is
literally being called traitorous
treasonous and I don't know what we're
going to do because if we can't discuss
the issue how could we think about our
policy but there is a good piece of news
and I'll state it quickly
ever since the Soviet Union ended
relations with Russia have gotten worse
and worse and now we are where we are
and we ask ourselves why did that happen
communism is gone the Soviet Union is
gone and the answer here is always it's
an orthodoxy it's it's biblical
you can't dissent from it without being
accused of being Pro Kremlin the answer
is Russia's to blame Putin is to blame
the United States has done nothing wrong
and now the President of the United
States has said some has said something
absolutely heretic oh he said it first
in a tweet and then after
meeting with Putin and it was very
simple but it was profoundly true he
said we had bad relations today because
both sides are to blame I think that's
what underlies their fury at him that he
has become a heretic in the American
policy system he has he has challenged
the fundamental axiom yes American
foreign policy for 25 years well it's
stupid I mean what's what's true in
Foreign Relations is true in marriage
it's always a joint effort to screw
something up so quickly it is true
actually well as you know but I'm go I'm
not going there no matter what you say
give us a sense quickly of the
consequences of what's at stake here I
think for a lot of Americans this is a
political story but it's also a
geopolitical story this is a country
with a lot of weapons it sees the world
very differently from us so what are we
playing with here all right leave this
Russia gate aside because I can't find a
fact to support it what President Trump
has done and in this regard though I
didn't vote for him I say three cheers
for president Trump he has said look we
are in a dangerous situation with Russia
and it's not just Russia this to blame
we're to blame we did wrongheaded things
back in the 90s and since what we need
to do this is me speaking now having
acknowledged that is have a discussion
of where our policy toward Russia went
wrong first under Clinton then under
Bush then under Obama it is a fully
bipartisan but what Trump has given us
if the media would allow him is an
opportunity to rethink and if you don't
rethink how do you get policy right and
if it's don't get policy right we are
talking about war yeah well this is a
city like Seinfeld that refuses to learn
anything ever professor thank you very
much great to see you